.
>>> BREAKING NEWS.
THAT'S RIGHT.
IT IS JOBS DAY.
THE LABOR DEPARTMENT RELEASED
THE SEPTEMBER JOBS REPORT AND
THE ECONOMY ADDED 336,000 NEW
JOBS LAST MONTH.
STRAIGHT TO RAHEL SOLOMON TO
BREAK DOWN THE NUMBERS.
WOW, AGAIN.
>> WOW.
>> THE LAST 15 MONTHS IT'S BEEN
LIKE THAT.
>> CLEARLY HOT, GUYS.
TO PUT THIS IN PERSPECTIVE, THIS
IS ABOUT DOUBLE WHAT ECONOMISTS
WERE EXPECTING.
AS YOU SAID, 336,000 ADDED IN
THE MONTH OF SEPTEMBER
THE EXPECTATION WAS CLOSER TO
170.
THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE REMAINING
STEADY AT 3.8%.
WAGES MODERATING A BIT.
THAT HAS AN INFLATIONARY IMPACT.
LET'S LOOK AT WHERE WE SAW SOME
OF THE STRONGEST JOB GAINS.
SOME A CONTINUATION OF WHAT WE
HAVE SEEN.
LEISURE AND HOSPITALITY, ADDING
JOBS THERE.
HEALTH CARE, ADDING JOBS THERE.
GUYS, THIS IS AN INTERESTING ONE
BECAUSE ALL WEEK WE HAVE BEEN
GETTING THESE CONFLICTING
REPORTS ABOUT THE STATE OF THE
LABOR MARKET S IT COOLING?
IS IT HEATING UP?
THIS SEEMS TO SUGGEST IT'S HOT,
RIGHT?
SO JUST TO GIVE SU SOME
PERSPECTIVE OVER THE LAST MONTH,
LAST YEAR, RATHER, WE HAVE SEEN
AN AVERAGE MONTHLY GAIN OF
271,000 AND THIS IS ON TOP OF
THAT.
REVISIONS, VERY IMPORTANT HERE.
FOR THE PRIOR TWO MONTHS ADDED
AN ADDITIONAL 120,000 JOBS, MORE
THAN EXPECTED.
120,000 JOBS MORE THAN EXPECTED.
SO IT'S A STRONG LABOR MARKET,
GREAT FOR THE AMERICAN WORKER.
IN TERMS OF WHAT THIS MEANS IN
FIRMS OF THE FED, THIS SEEMS TO
SUGGEST WHEN THEY MEET THE END
OF THIS MONTH, OCTOBER 31 TO
NOVEMBER 1, THE CHANCES OF
ANOTHER RATE HIKE HAVE
INCREASED.
>> YEAH.
IT IS AMAZING WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE NUMBERS AND PUT IN
PERSPECTIVE, TOO, OVER THE PAST
12 MONTHS.
WHAT WE ARE GETTING TODAY, MORE
REVISIONS UPWARD.
WITH US, CNN ECONOMICS
COMMENTATOR KATHERINE, WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THIS, IT'S FASCINATING
BECAUSE WE ARE HEARING FROM THE
PRESIDENT LATER TODAY, WHO WILL
SPEAK AFTER A STRONG JOBS
REPORT.
THERE HAS BEEN THIS CONSISTENT
ATTEMPTED PUSH AT BIDENOMICS AND
SELLING HOW MUCH THIS STRONG
ECONOMY IS DUE TO THE
PRESIDENT'S ACTIONS.
>> DO THESE CONTINUED JOBS
REPORTS, ARE THEY CHIPPING AWAY
AT THAT?
ARE THEY STARTING TO HELP MAKE
THAT CASE?
>> THEY CERTAINLY DON'T HURT.
THESE NUMBERS ARE REALLY, REALLY
STRONG.
NOW, I WOULD TAKE ALL OF THEM
WITH A LITTLE BIT OF GRAIN OF
SALT BECAUSE THERE IS, LIKE,
WACKY SEASONALITY HAPPENING
HERE, THE STRIKES PROBABLY ARE
NOT INCLUDED, NOT ACCOUNTED FOR.
EVEN SO, THESE ARE VERY STRONG
NUMBERS.
TO WHAT EXTENT BIDEN CAN TAKE
CREDIT FOR HIM, HE WILL TAKE
CREDIT NO MATTER WHAT, YOU KNOW?
WE ARE SEEING A HOT ECONOMY
HERE.
LOOK, A LOT OF SECTORS ARE DOING
MUCH
MUCH BETTER THAN MANY EXPECTED.
FOOD SERVICES, FOR EXAMPLE, IS
BACK TO ITS PRE-PANDEMIC HIGHS.
ANOTHER THING THAT AGAIN I DON'T
KNOW IF IT'S EXACTLY DUE TO
BIDEN VERSUS OTHER FACTORS,
THAT'S WORTH NOTING, IS THAT
WOMEN'S LABOR FORCE
PARTICIPATION, AT LEAST FOR
PRIME WORKING AGE WOMEN, AT A
RECORD HIGH.
THROUGH THIS REPORT.
SO THERE IS A LOT OF GOOD NEWS
TO TOUT.
AND I THINK THE PRESIDENT'S
ATTITUDE WILL BE, IF HE IS GOING
TO GET BLAMED FOR BAD STUFF, HE
MIGHT AS WELL HAVE THE GOOD
STUFF, TOO.
>> I HAVE TO IMAGINE WHAT
FUTURES ARE DOING NOW.
THIS WAS THE WEEK WHERE I FEEL
LIKE NEWSPAPER HAD THE FRONT
PAGE STORY OF RATES ARE REALLY
GOING TO START TO BITE FINALLY
OVER TIME AND MARKET
PARTICIPANTS ARE RECOGNIZING
THAT.
>> WELL, THAT SELLS THE PICTURE,
RIGHT?
JUST BEFORE THE NUMBERS CROSSED
WE LOOKED AT FUTURE AND THE DOW
WAS UP SLIGHTLY AS SOON AS THEY
CROSSED, THEY TANKED 180 POINTS.
NOW OFF 180 POINTS.
THE REASON WHY, I MEAN, THIS IS
GOOD NEWS FOR THE AMERICAN
WORKER.
GOOD NEWS ABOUT THE LABOR
MARKET, EXCEPT THAT IT MEANS
THAT THE FEDERAL RESERVE THAT
JAY POWELL AND THAT COMMITTEE,
IT NOW SORT OF GIVES THEM A BIT
MORE PUSH TO INCREASE RATES
FURTHER.
AND WE HAVE ALREADY SEEN 11 RATE
HIKES SINCE MARCH OF 2022, 2021.
LET ME GET MY MATH -- 2022.
THE YEAR HAS GONE BY -- SO WE
HAVE SEEN 11 RATE HIKES.
THEY HAVE BOOSTED RATES 5%.
YET, THE RECESSION THAT SO MANY
PEOPLE THOUGHT WAS INEVITABLE
NEVER MATERIALIZED.
EVERY TIME THE FED RAISES RATES,
IT MAKES BORROWING MORE
EXPENSIVE.
WE ARE IN THIS PERIOD WHERE GOOD
NEWS IS BAD NEWS, WEIRD NEWS.
THAT IS THE SPACE --
>> THE ALTERNATE UNIVERSE WE
HAVE BEEN LIVING IN WHERE NONE
OF IT MAKES SENSE.
YOU MENTION THE STRIKES, LIKELY
NOT INVOLVED IN THESE NUMBERS.
WHEN W
WHEN WILL WE HAVE A SENSE OF
THAT?
>> DEPENDS HOW LONG THE STRIKES
CONTINUE.
ONE WOULD IMAGINE THAT THE UAW
STRIKES MIGHT APPEAR IN NEXT
MONTH'S REPORT.
SO RATHER THE REPORT THAT COMES
OUT FOR THE MONTH OF OCTOBER.
THAT IS RELEASED IN EARLY
NOVEMBER.
IF THE STRIKES CONTINUE THROUGH
THE WEEK WHERE THEY CONDUCT THE
SURVEY.
THE DIFFICULTY WITH ALL OF THIS
IS THAT EVEN THOUGH THESE
NUMBERS ARE REPORTED AS BEING A
MONTHLY NUMBER, THEY ARE REALLY
FOCUSING ON A SNAPSHOT IN TIME
DURING THAT MONTH.
SO THAT'S WHY YOU DON'T SEE THEM
IN THESE DATA BUT MAY SEE THEM
IN THE FOLLOWING MONTH'S DATA.
SAIL SAME WITH THE WRITERS
STRIKE ENDING.
YOU MIGHT SEE A LITTLE BUMP IN
NEXT MONTH'S REPORT BECAUSE
THOSE PEOPLE WENT BACK TO WORK
THIS MONTH.
MATT EGAN IS IN NEW YORK TO
HELP BREAK THIS ALL DOWN.
LET'S JUST HAVE A LOOK AT THE
HEADLINE NUMBER.
IT IS SUPER SPECTACULAR.
IT HAS TO BE SAID, IT JUST
EXPLAIN WHERE THOSE JOBS ARE,
AND WHY THIS NUMBER IS
SIGNIFICANT?
>> WELL BECKY, THIS REALLY WAS
A BLOCKBUSTER NUMBER.
336,000 JOBS ADDED LAST MONTH.
THAT'S ROUGHLY TWICE WHAT
PEOPLE WERE EXPECTING.
BUT NOT ONLY THAT, THIS IS
80,000 JOBS MORE THAN THE MOST
OPTIMISTIC FORECASTER HAD BEEN
PENCILLING IN.
THAT IS PRETTY INCREDIBLE.
AND THIS IS AN ACCELERATION
FROM AUGUST.
WHICH, BY THE WAY, WAS ALSO
REVISED HIGHER.
WE LOOK AT THE CHART, WE CAN
SEE THAT IN SOME WAYS, THIS
JOBS MARKET, APPARENTLY, IS
ACTUALLY HEATING UP AND A TIME
WHEN A LOT OF PEOPLE THOUGHT IT
WAS COOLING DOWN.
AND SO TO PUT A PERSPECTIVE OF
THESE FEARS OF AN IMMINENT OR
ONGOING RECESSION, YOU KNOW,
CLEARLY, THAT IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
THERE IS NOTHING ABOUT THESE
NUMBERS THAT SPEAK TO AN
IMMINENT RECESSION.
BUT OF COURSE, THE OTHER BIG
CONCERN OUT THERE IS INFLATION
AND THE FEDS WAR ON INFLATION.
SO, IF YOU ARE A BIG FEAR IS
THE FED IS GOING TO END UP
OVERDOING IT, OR THE BOMB
MARKET IS GOING TO TIGHTEN
THINGS FOR THE FED AND OVERDO
IT, THOSE FEARS ARE STILL VERY
MUCH ALIVE BECAUSE OF TODAY'S
NUMBER.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE HOPING FOR
GOLDILOCKS.
NOT TO, HOT NOT TOO COLD.
WE ENDED UP GETTING SOMETHING
THAT WAS MUCH CLOSER TO TOO
HOT.
AND THAT IS WHY WE HAVE THE
NEGATIVE REACTION IN THE STOCK
MARKET, WITH U.S. STOCKS
OPENING UP I WOULD SAY MODESTLY
LOWER.
BUT THERE IS POTENTIAL THAT IF
BOND YIELDS KEEP GOING HIGHER
TODAY AND IN THE COMING DAYS,
WE COULD SEE AN EVEN MORE
NEGATIVE REACTION IN THE STOCK
MARKET.
BECKY?
>> YES, FASCINATING, ISN'T IT?
AND ON OTHER WORLDS SORT OF TOP
BANKERS, JAMIE DIAMOND, HAS
BEEN TALKING ABOUT HIS CONCERNS
ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY OF THE
FED PUSHING RATES HIGHER.
NOT BEING AT THE END OF ITS
RATES RISING CYCLE, AND THAT
REALLY DOES BEG THE QUESTION.
HOW'S THE CENTRAL BANK GOT THIS
SORT OF LANDING, YOU KNOW, IN
HAND?
IS IT A SOFTER IS A HARD
LANDING?
AND THERE'S A REAL DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE TWO AND THE IMPACT
COULD BE VERY SQUINTING.
OIL PRICES.
WE TALK ABOUT INFLATION, THE
GOOD NEWS THIS WEEK, WE'VE SEEN
A SLOWDOWN, A SLIP, IN THE
PRICE OF OIL.
WE HAVE BEEN LOOKING, YOU KNOW,
ONLY A WEEK AGO, THE
POSSIBILITY OF 100 BUCKS ON THE
BARREL.
DOWN CLOSER TO SORT OF 18 BUCKS
ON THE BARREL LEVEL AT THIS
POINT.
WHY?
>> BECKY, THAT HAS BEEN JUST A
HUGE TURNAROUND.
YOU KNOW BETTER THAN ANYONE
THAT THE OIL MARKET IS
NOTORIOUSLY BOOM TO BUST.
BUT EVEN FOR THE OIL MARKET,
THIS IS A COMPLETELY INCREDIBLE
180.
BECAUSE JUST A WEEK AGO OR SO,
WE SAW U.S. OIL AND THERE WAS
BRENT ON THE CHART, YOU COULD
SEE GOING UP TOWARDS $100 OF
APPAREL.
THAT WAS SETTING OFF ALL KINDS
OF ALARM BELLS IN WASHINGTON,
WALL STREET, ABOUT INFLATION,
ABOUT GASOLINE PRICES, AND THEY
HAD COMPLETELY CRATERED SINCE
THEN.
AS FAR AS WHY?
THERE IS A SENSE THAT THE
BULLISH SENTIMENT GOT OVER
DONE.
THE PRICES GOT AHEAD OF
FUNDAMENTALS, WHICH IS KNOWN TO
HAPPEN FROM TIME TO TIME IN THE
FINANCIAL MARKETS, ESPECIALLY
IN ENERGY MARKETS.
, YOU KNOW HEDGE FUNDS WERE
KIND OF PILING ON, AND
EVENTUALLY, THEY RAN OUT OF
BUYERS, AND THE FUNDAMENTALS
JUST DID NOT SUPPORT TRIPLE
DIGIT OIL.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
SAUDI ARABIA AND RUSSIA DOING
BASICALLY EVERYTHING THEY CAN
TO PUMP UP OIL PRICES.
THAT STRATEGY HAD BEEN WORKING,
AND RIGHT NOW, IT'S NOT WORKING
SO MUCH.
BUT FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF
CONSUMERS, HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES AND AROUND THE WORLD,
THIS IS REALLY GOOD NEWS,
BECAUSE IT MEANS THAT RETAIL
ENERGY PRICES, GASOLINE PRICES,
CAN COOL DOWN.
I TALKED TO A VETERAN ENERGY
ANALYST HERE IN THE U.S., TOM
CLOSE AND.
HE TOLD ME HE THINKS GASOLINE
PRICES IN THE U.S. ARE GOING TO
GO TOWARDS 3:25 A GALLON BY THE
END OF THE MONTH.
THAT'S DOWN FROM AROUND 375
RIGHT NOW, SO, THAT WOULD BE
HUGE.
THE OIL PRICE DROP, BECKY, IS
ALSO VERY IMPORTANT FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF CENTRAL BANKERS,
BECAUSE IT HELPS THEM IN THEIR
FIGHT TO GET INFLATION UNDER
CONTROL.